mark paletta is an attorney a close
friend of clarence thomas he is a new
book called created equal clarence
thomas in his own words and film we just
interviewed him the other day he joins
us again tonight mark thanks so much for
coming on so it it does seem like so you
had six supreme court justices vote to
overturn roe v wade again you could be
for legal abortion and still recognize
roe v wade was an absurd supreme court
decision that degraded the institution
of the court and be against it but why
thomas why are they going after one
out of six
because the left is racist
tucker they expect clarence thomas to
think the way a black man should be in
in based on the color of his skin and
clarence thomas for 30 years 40 years
has refused to do that and they want to
destroy him and that's what they've been
doing and coming after him and the
bottom line is clarence thomas doesn't
care at all what they think
it's just so funny though i mean if you
compare the attitudes of the average
black guy in america to the average
weight liberal in america on abortion
the black guy's way more opposed to
abortion than the average weight liberal
so why does clarence thomas have to have
the same views as an npr listener
and that's what he's been saying for 40
years and it's the left demands it and
they will they will go after him but it
is a great day for the constitution uh
you know with with with roe being
overturned with with uh the second
amendment being strengthened consistent
with the constitution with religious
liberties today coming down uh
consistent with the constitution and
it's all aligning with where clarence
thomas has been for the past 30 years
yeah i think it's a fair point he's been
saying it this whole time as you point
out in your book mark great to see you
again thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight